associations et professionnels de santé
se prépare pour une mobilisation à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
contre l'épilepsie ce sera vendredi
cette maladie neurologique chronique et
se manifeste par des crises soudaines
mais quels sont les traitements
disponibles et que faire si vous êtes
face à une personne en crise on en parle
avec vous j'ai glissé guerre bonjour
julia sa touche combien de personnes
déjà et à quoi est ce dû ces crises
d'épilepsie alors on pense qu'il on
estime en tout cas qu'il ya environ 450
milles personnes épileptiques en france
et environ 40 voire même 50 millions
dans le monde avec une légère
prédominance masculine alors les crises
sont provoquées en fait par une
hyperactivité d'un d'un groupe de
neurones dans le cerveau ce qui se passe
vous le savez dans le cerveau c'est que
les neurones vont communiquer entre
elles grâce à des signaux qui sont
chimiques ou électrique et il peut
arriver qu'un groupe de neurones en fait
soudainement et il y à différentes
raisons pour cela mais soudainement
devienne le siège en fait d'une
hyperactivité électrique excessive et
désorganisés qui fait que ça crée
effectivement ce que l'on appelle une
crise d'épilepsie alors ça peut arriver
de façon locale ça peut se propager dans
d'autres parties du cerveau voire même
être généralisé caen s'est généralisé
c'est une crise tonico cloniques c'est
ce à quoi on pense naturellement quand
on pense à une crise d'épilepsie c'est
vraiment là où la personne va perdre
connaissance tomber par terre voire même
convulsé et vomir mais il peut y avoir
des crises beaucoup moins
impressionnante entre guillemets ou la
personne ne perd pas connaissance alors
ça touche les jeunes comme les moins
jeunes mais souvent ça apparaît plutôt
pendant l'enfance dans 10 à 15% des cas
d'ailleurs c'est congénitale mais ça
peut aussi apparaître effectivement
beaucoup plus tard dans la vie souvent
après un accident qui va créer des
lésions cérébrales comme par exemple en
avait c'est alors qu'est ce qu'une très
pratico pratique si on se retrouve
devant quelqu'un qui est en train de
faire une crise comment doit-on réagir
alors déjà il faut savoir que c'est
impossible d'arrêter une crise donc s'il
faut surtout pouvoir être proche du
patient et pouvoir l'assister alors il y
a des choses à faire effectivement la
première chose à faire c'est de le
placer la personne en position latérale
de sécurité c'est de s'assurer que les
voies respiratoires reste complètement
dégagé desserrer les vêtements essaient
de sécuriser la tête et surtout
d'essayer de chronométrer la crise on
dit qu en général si la crise dure plus
de quatre minutes il faut alors alerté
les secours les choses à ne surtout pas
faire essayer de transporter par exemple
à personne
de d'essayer de gêner et de contraindre
ses mouvements et surtout ne rien lui
donner à voir et ne pas mettre les mains
dans la bouche parce que là c'est la
morsure assuré alors on dit souvent
qu'il ya un risque que la personne
puisse avalé sa langue
absolument et bien en fait c'est un
mythe ce n'est pas possible avalé sa
langue pendant une crise épileptique par
contre encore une fois ce qui est
important c'est de dégager les voies
respiratoires de tout objet par exemple
il ya des traitements disponibles
j'imagine certains qui fonctionne mieux
d'autres absolument alors il ya des
traitements on peut par exemple passer
par la chirurgie ou la neurostimulation
il y a aussi des médicaments
antiépileptiques qui sont sur le marché
qui fonctionne bien mais qui viennent
souvent avec de nombreux effets
secondaires comme par exemple la fatigue
la somnolence le gain ou la perte de
poids voire même la dépression et des
problèmes d'élocution et c'est pour ça
que les scientifiques s'intéressent
effectivement au cannabis thérapeutique
notamment chez l'enfant figurez-vous une
étude vient de prouver que ça pouvait
réduire de 80 6% elles et les crises
épileptiques chez les enfants alors il
faut savoir que dans le cannabis
thérapeutique il ya environ ou dans le
cannabis en tout cas il y as 400 entités
chimiques qui peuvent être utilisés de
manière thérapeutique mais bon prescrire
de la drogue pour les enfants ce n'est
pas facile c'est un geste loin d'être
anodin et puis il faut souligner qu'une
prise excessive est évidemment de de
cannabis peut endommager sérieusement le
cerveau une autre actualité qui qui
ouvre finalement de nouvelles voies
thérapeutiques c'est la greffe de
neurones absolument l'expérience a été
fait sur une otarie californienne qui
est devenu en fait épileptique suite à
une intoxication à des algues son nom
ses chronos temps lui a en fait greffer
des neurones de porcins en 2020 et il
semblerait aujourd'hui ça y est on a des
nouvelles qu'elle serait complètement
guérie qu'il n'y aurait plus de deux
crises d'épilepsie selon cette étude
justement et bien ça recèle d'énormes
promesses thérapeutique aussi pour
l'homme ce qu'on a fait en fait c'est
qu'on lui a administré dans son
hippocampe environ 200000 neurones 2% et
voilà il pour éviter d'ailleurs tout
rejet l'animal a aussi dû recevoir un
traitement immuno suppresseurs avant
même cette cette intervention qui a
quand même duré cinq heures hier se
trouvait d'ailleurs suivre cette otaries
sur sur twitter elle un compte twitter
entendu elle continue à tweeté sur son
état de santé voire malik et les
nouvelles de l'otarie alors merci
beaucoup julia siggers c'était